You've heard all the scary
rumors surrounding vaccines.
They cause autism.
They contain toxins,
even that they can give you the
disease that they're trying to prevent.
It's misinformation like this that has
caused American vaccination rates to drop
significantly over the
past couple of decades.
Some people believe their children
would be better off in a world without
vaccines. What do they fully grasp?
What that world would look like?
What kind of diseases would be
welcomed back into our lives?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen
if we stopped vaccinations.
Through the years,
vaccines have been successful in reducing
the spread of deadly diseases like
measles, diptheria and rubella
to the point where they've
nearly disappeared from
America.
When people stop seeing these diseases,
some start to wonder why we're still
vaccinating against them. Well,
if you want to see how a so called
controlled disease can make a comeback,
just ask the people of Japan.
Let me paint a picture for you.
It's 1974 in Japan and 80% of people
were getting the whooping cough vaccine
with only 393 cases of whooping cough
and zero related deaths throughout the
whole country. That year, the Japanese
started to let their guard down.
By 1979 only 10% of children
were being vaccinated.
The result was a whopping 13,000 cases
that year and 41 related deaths shocked
by the whole ordeal.
The Japanese quickly turned
back to routine vaccination
and the disease numbers
dropped.
Once again.
People usually see the decision not to
vaccinate as a very personal individual
matter thinking they shouldn't have the
right to be able to control what goes
into their child's
body. Sure, we get that,
but what a lot of people don't understand
is that if everyone made the same
individual decision,
it would have catastrophic effects and
eventually spell far more danger for your
child. The fewer people who get
vaccinated, the more opportunities, uh,
disease has to spread.
When you decide not to get vaccinated,
you're not only accepting the possibility
of contracting a disease yourself,
but also the chance of
spreading it to others.
Around you and playing
a part in an epidemic.
There are hundreds of thousands of
people who can't get vaccinated due to
treatments for cancer or other conditions
and their safety relies on the rest of
us being vaccinated.
The next time someone tries to convince
you that vaccines are too dangerous,
just let them consider what our world
would look like. Without vaccines,
we'd be transported back to a world we
thought we had overcome where life for
children was especially brutal in America.
Every year,
48,000 people would be hospitalized
with measles and 500 would die.
The chicken box would cause 10,000
children to be hospitalized and between 70
and 100 would die and hepatitis A and
B would reemerge as silent epidemic
affecting millions of people.
These are just a handful of
the old diseases that would
come back to wreak havoc
if we all stopped vaccinations.
So why stop?
There hasn't been a single credible
study linking vaccines to longterm health
conditions.
In fact,
the paper that started the theory that
vaccines cause autism was so discredited
that the author
lost his medical license.
Maybe one day we'll be able to
eradicate all diseases from our planet,
but with new challenges just
come to take their place. Well,
that's a topic for another.
What if
that was what if, and here's what will
happen. If you click like or subscribe,
we'll get to make more of the
videos you love, educate the masses,
and maybe even save the world.
There's only one way to find out.